فيما بدا تدرجا في التحرك الميداني ومع
مرور الساعات في اطار عمليه ثار الاحرار
وسعد الفصائل الفلسطينيه من دائره
استهدافاتها تخطط مستوطنات غلاف غزه وقصفت
مدن اسرائيليه قصف نزع عن الاسرائيليين
الشعور بالامن داخل مجتمعاتهم هكذا ينقل
عنهم الاعلام الاسرائيلي
[موسيقى]
الصفارات طاردتني وكانت الصواريخ فوق
سيارته شعرت بالخطر وتوقفت للدخول الى
منطقه محميه نريد ان نهرب من هذا الواقع
الصعب تمر الصواريخ من فوقنا ونسمع
الانفجارات هذا واقع تعيس وسائل اعلام
الاسرائيليه ابرزت ما وصفته حاله الشلل
التي اطبقت على اسرائيل مع هروب قرابه
مليوني اسرائيلي الى الملاجئ وصفه الامر
بالانجاز لصالح الجهاد الاسلامي
هذا صحيح هناك انتهاك للسياده وهناك
مسؤوليه على اسرائيل تجاه شعبها الجهاد
الاسلامي اعاق الحياه في اسرائيل هذا
بالتاكيد ينقص من الانجاز العسكري تفتيش
الاسرائيليين عن ملجا اثناء ذوي صفارات
الانذار ينطبق ايضا على بعض مسؤول الحكومه
وهو ما تظهره صور التقطت لوزيره النقل
ميريغيف اثناء توجهها الى احد الملاجئ في
اسدود لحظه سقوط صواريخ اطلقتها الفصائل
من غزه